I'd run you
hard on you
thought from you
there's no tears left to cry because
Ariana Grande's releasing new music with
a very special friend the weekend it's a
very exciting thing for us
the two artists are once again joining
forces their very first collab came in
2014 for Ariana's track Love Me Harder
if you
do it
[Music]
then again in 2021 for a remix of the
weekend song save your tears
and seems the weekend's not finished
with his Starboy era they're now
dropping a remix of his 2016 track die
for you with Ari sharing this snippet
behind the scenes in the studio
hard on you
hide from you
the singer teased in the caption wrote
and recorded a verse for my friend after
a 14-hour day on set this certain
exception had to be made do whatever you
want whatever you want whatever feels
natural be yourself and that set Ari's
talking about is wicked the pop star is
currently shooting the film adaptation
of the Broadway musical starring as
Glinda the Good Witch a role made
Popular by Kristen Chenoweth Popular
you're gonna be popular I'll teach you
the proper Poise when you talk to boys
little ways I've known Ariana Grande
since she was 10. so Ariana I'm very
very proud of you she knows we talk
every day I love you baby girl and it's
an honor and a pleasure to pass the wand
and the crown to you
and just weeks ago Ari reminded fans why
she hasn't released any new music it was
like so crazy a fan asked why aren't you
still a singer and Ari responded with
I'm literally on set filming two musical
movies all day every day but she still
gave fans a little something when she
belted out somewhere over the rainbow
play
alone for the rainbow
I always listen to their feedback and
try to incorporate as much of it as I
can while also remaining as you know
true to my Artistry as I possibly can
the wicked films will come out in two
installments arriving Christmas 2024 and
2025. in the meantime fans will soon be
able to enjoy Ari and the weeknd's new
song The Die For You remix comes out
February 23rd
[Music]
thank you